think you're talking out of your ass  here and here's why because  nothing i love nachos i love nachos i  never feel sick after sushi outside of  the way you could feel sick if you ate  too much of anything there's something  to like i am stuffed and knowing that  it's raw fish that is way more  disgusting than oh my god i had pico de  gallo corn tortilla  chopped meat sour cream shredded cheese  tomato disagree that's insane i got the  best nachos i've ever had in my life i  don't want to see him again for a week  sushi is a roll of the dice  and get a great plate of nachos no you  couldn't every time every time you have  sushi you're risking your life you're  risking your life you couldn't you were  blindfolded you're eating nachos or a  burrito you couldn't tell the difference  outside of the crowd  [Music]